i was younger and i did coke oh that was
dick for [ __ ] four hours
yeah you just was giving out dick
they're looking at you like when is this
gonna stop
and then when you do come it's one of
those long loads yeah
you ever have those loads like i used to
i used to be on probation
and there was a dude that was like a gi
joe dude that failed the police test
but his assistant was a good looking
woman like she was kind of cute
if i was 30 she was by 38 nobody talked
to her in boulder because she had like a
wooden leg
like her leg was kind of like she had
like that little limp
but you could tell the [ __ ] had game
like she could suck a [ __ ] i would look
at my eyes and i could tell this [ __ ]
is deadly
but nobody talks to her because of the
[ __ ] wooden leg or whatever the [ __ ]
she's got she got shot in vietnam i
didn't know what happened i figured out
how to [ __ ] with the piss test
but with me they had mirrors around me
they couldn't figure out what i was
doing
so they sent her and so before i would
go and i'd
[ __ ] do a half a jerk in the car and
get my dick nice and big
yeah and then i'd sprinkle it the
[ __ ] uh pool cleaner
pool cleaner it doesn't sting your dick
the pool did nice i got scars i got
little holes in my dick and
uh drano i would grind it up i would
[ __ ] put it under my
dick and then pull the skin back and it
would fall into the piss test and zap it
but before i would piss i would take the
hammer out and show it though like what
do you think
what do you think there's something nice
and she would look at it and look around
the room
and not like i knew i was going to end
up sleeping with her or swapping spirit
because i flirt with it nobody talked to
the woman because
she had a [ __ ] up leg so i'm off
probation i'm delivering chinese food
i'm slinging coke at the same time at
the chinese restaurant
so i would have to i would have you call
the chinese restaurant and say
i talked to joey yeah what's up oh you
wanna drop soup whatever
the cocaine would be hidden under the
egg drop soup so if i got in trouble the
chinese people got in trouble
i didn't put in the bag this is when i
was out already out of prison
one night i knock on the door who
answers the door it's her
and she goes oh my god it's so great to
see you
how have you been like oh it's great to
see you man i gave her a hug
and i put the chinese down and she goes
what are you doing with your life i i'm
getting divorced
but i got into stand-up comedy and i'm
trying to deliver food to make a living
and
she's like oh that's so sweet you you
and her broke up oh you must need a hug
and as i started hugging we started swap
and spit
and i touched a little monkey and i
could feel nobody had even touched a
monkey in like 10 years
steam started coming and i started
fingering that [ __ ] like a
savage and swamp and spit with her
and my hand was nice and wet and i'm
finger that i got a pinky surrounded her
[ __ ]
and i'm working and finally i put it
down slowly and i
pop her pants i take her out she's got
one big [ __ ] damn
pitch
at the same time so while i'm fingering
i take her pants down but i go i don't
want to see what the other leg is
so i took the leg off with a good leg
and i left the [ __ ] bad leg cubbie
because i don't want to know what it is
if she's got like a pole under there one
of those [ __ ] up feet
so i picked up a [ __ ] leg when i
started eating a [ __ ] the [ __ ]
[ __ ] was huge i'm sucking out like a
peeling
like a piece of bubble come on look up
at it and she's like this christine like
with her mouth open i go now is the time
to put the helmet in that [ __ ] mouth
so i switched up i started two-finger
louisiana and i went around there
and i put that [ __ ] hammer in her
mouth and she didn't know what to do she
was
like
that was and at that time and at that
time
i was trying to [ __ ] lift weights and
[ __ ] so i wasn't jerking off
because somebody told me i had to jerk
off that you're protein i was [ __ ]
yeah you haven't taught it yeah
and when i came in the mouth it was one
of those loads christine that don't stop
you didn't have one of those things i
know you're sucking it
you're sucking it with your eyes closed
and then after a minute you open it up
because you're like what is this going
to stop and i could look at a swallow in
it
and it was endless it was [ __ ]
endless it was just a load of death
it was like a month and a half are not
coming there was valium in there and
xanax
and [ __ ] so nice seeing you joey
thanks for stopping
by she looked at me she started getting
a little dizzy
because i was selling valium at the time
i was taking like 100 milligrams of
valium a night
when i shot in her mouth put her in a
trance
she was glassy eyed she gave me a three
dollar tip and i left
and i never saw her again she must have
ate that chinese from the slept for a
week oh my god
oh do you got any dates coming up you
wanna
wait a minute you didn't even bang her
you don't put it in her vagine
no no that's that's the procedure
once i shove my tongue in your ass you
black out it's like it's like you're 14
and your uncle's more lost
you just black out and what happened
what's gonna happen anyway
this is too good you almost hospitalized
me one time
from laughing so hard like i don't know
if you remember this
i'm serious ugh i don't know if i could
tell it
it was it was backstage
oh it was backstage at his show we were
somewhere
and you were like how's the wife oh
good and you and i go you go where is
she and i said i said some city in
tennessee
maybe knoxville or nashville and you go
nashville
96 and you started the story about
working the club and you're like i just
rift in between
shows some crazy [ __ ] some chick who was
talking there was eight people for there
was 20 people for the first show
knoxville
it was a comedy zone show i have booked
it
knoxville is a great little [ __ ] town
like a cute little tennessee town
is it it's like hip it's a football you
know like a college town
so i get there on friday night joe rogan
i'm headlining i got 38 minutes
i just moved to la and i signed with
creative management
and they booked those rooms so they were
booking me out as a headliner i was just
dying slowed that so what they did was
they put me in one nighters
that paid like 275 and nine they weren't
bad quiet tennessee
you know and we go to this knoxville for
two nights and i go in there and you
know me dog i'm [ __ ] crazy
first night i go in there too from
friday night there's 20 people for the
first show
and there's a girl joe rogan that's a
12.
with a guy that's a four okay and it's
her birthday you know meanwhile drew and
she just turned 21
it's her birthday okay hey happy
birthday
what's going on here you know because
once you start hearing noise you have to
react to it as a comment
and you know what's going on here 21. i
said you're very beautiful
and then she just went and ran with it
and started talking about how
her husband pimps her out he would have
fights on
and for 20 bucks you could [ __ ] her in
the back room 20 fights were on whatever
i don't know that on fridays he would
bring it to the
construction truck
with her to the construction site and
put a mattress in the back
and at lunch time that he would let her
friends and she's telling me this
it's like she's talk and people like
like
just holding their breaths like what is
going on here this girl is beautiful
and this [ __ ] is just pimping him
so in between shows i go upstairs to do
a line or smoke a
joint or whatever the [ __ ] i'm doing
when i come back i see her
by herself when we start talking and
what's going on oh my god i had such a
great time
i go is that stuff true and she goes
yeah go show me the monkey and she put
me in the woman's bathroom
pulled down her pants the girl had a
monkey that was spotless
it nearly stunk i ate it i fingered or
something and then she
sucked my dick that was it i went back
to my room i didn't think nothing of it
i'm like jesus christ i scored
i go back for the second show there's ap
but by the time i go back for the second
show joe rogan
she's sitting in the back she's 21 and
she's looking at me like this
she's [ __ ] up and 10 minutes into my
spot
set because i was headlining she starts
going i suck the comedian's dick tonight
my husband was like what are you talking
about
and she's like i suck this dick and he
came in my mouth he's like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about the
cops had to hold him back and he's like
i want my 40 that's all he wanted
he didn't care that his wife sucked my
dick at this comedy bathroom oh my god
when the cops came he kept saying
man somebody's gonna get hurt if i don't
have my 48 hours
that's a 40-hour blow job did you come
in her mouth
because if i wouldn't come would have
been like 20 all he cared about
was the 40 dog so he told me that
backstage
at your show and i [ __ ] started
hyperventilating
40 dollars